I feel like the only time that somebody
really challenged me on the porn [ __ ]
was maybe sneako who basically just
tried to convince me that I was like
doing a disservice to men all over the
world by making porn which I really
didn't feel too persuaded by especially
since there's just so much of it out
there already it just doesn't even feel
like I'm moving the needle in terms of
the total amount of porn out there what
do you think do you think do you think
it's [ __ ] up for me to be doing porn
am I wasting my potential as a human
being
oh gosh offend you morally
um
I don't really care what people do like
it's not really my not my problem no
offense
um do I think it's like a net good for
the world not really
um I would think more about like your
kids like it like I don't know I
personally think it'd be hard to grow up
with like a parent that does that stuff
that's kind of where my mind goes but
again that's respectfully it's like not
my problem yeah yeah I really don't care
about that you're gonna have to deal
with it
I just feel like there's that's like a
thing that a lot of people do though
where they try to take like the world is
pretty clearly divided into like kids
stuff and grown-up stuff like you know I
had some friends like these BMX dudes
right and they did like an anti-drug
seminar at the school one time and mad
people in the BMX world were like really
mad because they're like you guys drink
and you smoke weed and like how how can
you go to the school and tell these
five-year-olds not to do drugs and it's
like bro they're [ __ ] kids they're
like you know it's like the same thing
as driving a car like I don't want my
kid to drive a car but I don't feel bad
about driving a car in front of her well
I guess I guess I'd put it like this
growing up I really appreciated having
parents that like didn't have
like they were just really
clean like clean people in that regard
so like my dad doesn't drink he doesn't
smoke he doesn't have social media he
just works hard and like that's what he
does and it was just like nice to have
that to look up to I don't have to worry
about like my dad screwing someone I
know or like any of my parents exes
getting involved like they'd only been
with each other they met each other
maybe that's not like probable in
today's world but I just I just think
that's like there's less problems with
that definitely less problems because
when I think about the fact that it took
a long time for me to really like start
experimenting with drinking and stuff
and when I think about the fact that I
never really smoke cigarettes for a long
time when I was younger and stuff it's
really because my parents I never saw
them drink almost ever I never saw them
smoke I never even knew about I never
even considered the idea of them
cheating or anything like that I never
got divorced so you know I'm probably
better off as a result of that but at
the same time I feel like you know
at a certain point like your kids just
gotta kind of deal with your baggage
because that's the whole thing is that
there is this like interim time period
in a kid in a kid's life where like
there's there's kids stuff and there's
adult stuff and it's like a weird time
period where the kid knows about the
adult stuff that they can't have
anything to do with it would be like if
I if I owned a bar and it was always
this like kind of weird thing where like
the kid wants to go to the bar she wants
to she wants to go to Dad's work but she
can't go to Dad's work it's
inappropriate and you know it's like
it's definitely that's the weird thing
to navigate it was like your kid
understanding this grown-up stuff that
you're doing and not necessarily
do you think you're do you think you're
kind of like rolling the dice with that
um I think rolling having a kid in
general you're kind of rolling the dice
because you're sort of like
intentionally creating this thing that
you know at some point you're going to
be totally incapable of controlling in
any way right
and so yeah I mean I guess it's a little
bit more of a rolling of the dice but
like what's the worst scenario that she
like suffers some amount of like
bullying or has to deal with it to some
extent I mean I'm not that worried about
that would you be okay if she did porn
as an adult I don't think it would
really be my business but it definitely
wouldn't like encourage her to I'd want
to say or pursue anything else possible
before she made that decision sometimes
I feel like that's kind of the sad thing
is that I will be interviewing a girl
and I'll realize that she started only
fans when she was 18. I even had one
girl tell me that she was promoting her
only fans on social media when she was
17 in the lead up to like oh I'm turning
18 that's what I'm dropping the only
pads and I was just like what the [ __ ]
that that sounds like it should be
illegal I'm assuming it's not but like
an underage person promoting their
future porn release I don't know it just
sounded really creepy to me but I mean
you know every girl that I know for the
most part who does only fans or whatever
I don't see it as like a negative thing
in their life for the most part
everybody I know seems pretty happy
even when they get like older you think
yeah I mean I I do know some pornstar
chicks who end up resentful about what
they went through but I feel like in
large part they're the chicks who didn't
really like have control of their career
the Mia khalifas in the Lana Rhodes who
felt like they had to do all this crazy
ass sex [ __ ] because I know so many
girls never make [ __ ] loads of money on
only fans or whatever and they're just
posting like boob photos oh wow
yeah I mean it's it's like it's like not
my problem you know if they're happy
doing it that's fine I just
it's not my favorite thing you know it's
just not aesthetically you don't watch
porn no I've never seen it well okay I
was scarred once on Twitter so I don't
want to say I've never seen porn I was
scrolling I was like ah what is it but
outside of that I've never seen porn I
see porn probably like 50 times during
my early morning Twitter scroll yeah
well I haven't been that like active on
Twitter until the last like month or two
but it's interesting to me that there
are probably a lot of people like I see
twitch streamers looking at Twitter on
stream
and I'm like wow that's amazing you're
they're so confident that they're not
going to see porn that they feel
comfortable doing this I could never I'm
on conservative Twitter so I feel like
my Twitter's like yeah right but but
that day I was scarred scarred what did
you say what was going on were they
sweating
was there oil
no it was just like they're like
screwing I don't know
I don't know I was like uh no actually
I'm sorry I lied I saw porn one other
time because when I was in college I was
in I was in the dorm Lobby I forgot
about this and I told I I said this
again I was like I've never seen porn
and this is what guys do they'll be like
oh I need to show you now why would I
want to see that why would I want to sit
on there because they think if they show
you that that might get you in the mood
to do what you're seeing okay I was not
in the mood I was like I tried that
before right when I was young ah my eyes
my eyes but as a grown-up sometimes you
do like we do that we'll like watch some
porn and then inevitably we end up
[ __ ] it's like almost impossible to
watch people [ __ ] and not end up [ __ ]
from my perspective well I don't know
do you feel like okay how many people
have you slept with do you have this out
no you ask everybody that you don't say
your own number what
um no I don't ask everyone I don't think
I've ever asked no I don't even ask body
count it's a single digit no I say it it
is a single digit okay but um no I don't
even ask
um
I always say how many bodies is Too Many
Bodies or how many body so you become a
how the only time a girl has set her
body count on live I I swear to God I
was like okay guys what's your body
count I was like haha kidding you don't
have to say that this girl this girl was
like oh I'll tell you like I'm on the
sexual positivity and I was like I was
like um are you sure and then she was
like yeah and I was like okay go ahead
it was like it was a lot it was like 30
something or 40 I don't know how old
for you I don't know
um she was like 27 28 I think
um
uh okay but but um I was like
then she got mad and wanted me to take
the stream down but I'm like yeah but I
was like I didn't make you say anything
yeah I didn't make you like and then she
was like threatening to sue me and all
this stuff and I was just like ma'am I
said are you sure right so that was that
was the only time see that's interesting
because I feel like
I would encourage most people to not put
a hard number out there into the world
it's probably better I think for most
people it's advantageous to be sort of
vague about it yeah well I just I feel
like they never ever believe me any like
they wouldn't believe me anyway so it's
like
you see dudes say that all the time on
your [ __ ] or wherever whether it be like
you know
this is the number that I think that
that I would be comfortable with but
also I know that they're gonna lie so
it's like I know that if it's 10 then
it's really 30. or whatever yeah well
actually I know I know what men think
about body count okay I've actually
interviewed how many bodies is Too Many
Bodies or would you rather have a girl
that's taken 50 or or if it has fifty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
most guys say the debt but I do I do
think if they got debt is such a turn
off but but so when it comes to body
count guys say 10 right that's always
the number like if I say how many bodies
is Too Many Bodies the most common
answer I get is 10. however they mean 20
and this is what I mean I'll push it
because this is what I do I do this to
guys and girls like girls about income
or whatever and I'll be like okay but
this girl she's great she's got this
but she's got 15. they're like well and
I keep pushing it and it seems like 20
is like the real number guys say but if
they say 20 on the podcast it's like
embarrassing to them like they would
wife a girl with with 20.
um this is just and I'll see who they
date because you know like a lot of the
guests become regulars like I see who
they date outside the show I'm like I
know that girl I know what she was doing
before she met you but that's not the
bot that's not the number you said all
right this is this is my thing is that I
obviously am like more open-minded about
this kind of stuff especially in the
porn world you know it's like there's
infinite like super hot girls I know who
are like the most high valued chicks in
the industry and they've got like you
know hundreds of bodies like different
dudes that they [ __ ] on camera off
camera whatever and it's like totally
nobody cares about it in the same way
but then at the same time I will say
that most of the time when I see a porn
relationship not work out it's due to
some element of jealousy from even if
the guy does porn
like he will inevitably get jealous of
his girl working with other guys and it
will become a [ __ ] thing and it'll
start they'll become exclusive and then
at some point she wants to work with
other guys and it doesn't work out like
that I've seen that play out so many
times yeah
um so even the most open-minded sexually
people their relationships usually end
up ending over the guy being territory
about about her vagina that's just I
can't imagine letting other guys rail
your chick is a great way to go but I
mean this is just you know I think
that's playing the game on hard for sure
if you can if you can go through that as
a dude and not care because my girl
doesn't [ __ ] besides me and so it's
like I don't have to live the life of
sitting here interviewing you while
knowing that my girl is taking a 10 inch
long to the face which might be hard for
me I don't know I'm not [ __ ] Superman
I don't know if I could actually like be
cool with that I do know some guys who
are and I am kind of in awe of them
yeah that's a different different world
I don't know
that's the difference as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible